[Music]
hello there it's july in gaming this is
the month before the aaa games start
releasing and even though it's a slow
month i've found a handful of games
worth your time and money and a couple
of free experiences if you're saving
your cash for another time so let's do
this
the headline game of the month is all
about a cat stray a mystery solving
cyberpunk wandering delivery cat we are
tasked with reuniting our lost family
and solving an ancient mystery that
mystery i guess will be where the heck
are all the humans the greatest thing
about being a cat is the ability to go
almost anywhere and we'll also have our
own android too a drone named b12 if
you're a cat lover you're likely already
hyped for stray but even though i
dislike cats i'm kinda into this too
stray releases on july 19th on ps4 ps5
and pc and there is a kicker to stray
those on playstation plus will get it
for free but only those on the deluxe
version the premium version sony still
has a great deal of ironing out of ps
plus to be done so i wondered if you'd
be interested in a breakdown of the
service here in the uk we were the last
to get the new ps plus so i'm way behind
other content creators but i'd still
like to make it
another animal exploration game dropping
on july 19th is endling extinction is
forever a single-player 3d side-scroller
all about keeping the last of your
species alive we play as the motherfucks
trying to keep her cubs away from all
kinds of peril and onto safer pastures
the game describes itself as an
eco-conscious game which usually means
humans are depicted as the bad guys
building roads forcing toxins into
rivers you know good old humanity
forcing nature out of its home each cub
we raise is said to have its own
personality so one will be more
inquisitive and venture closer to danger
whereas another may be eaten by an owl
i'm not lying legit that could happen we
need to be observant as we search for a
safe place to take a nap endling retails
at around 30 that's 25 quid here in the
uk and comes to ps4 pc xbox and twitch
[Music]
july sees the release of arcade geddon
an ever evolving cooperative multiplayer
shooter their target audience is those
shooter fans and battle royale players
and all this comes at an entrance fee of
around twenty dollars there are rumors
that arcader geddon is coming to ps plus
but i can't comment on that right now
you should come back on wednesday
playstation fam here in arcade geddon
the premise season arcade owner
accidentally spread a dangerous virus to
all the machines and we must go in and
save the day it's been in early access
for almost a year now and in that time
we've seen many core games and mini
games too from surviving unlimited horde
to playing a futuristic basketball game
it appears that the basic foundations
are in place and pretty much anything
that can be imagined can be turned into
a game so it's effectively like fortnite
creative for people who've had enough
fortnite for now so will you try it
[Music]
speaking of free games here are a few
you can play right now firstly remember
the capcom arcade stadium i told you
about last year a hub application like
an arcade for all of capcom's retro
games to live in well randomly they give
away games for free from time to time
for a limited time and right now it's
possible to download street fighter 2
the world warrior totally free you'll
want to hurry though as this promotion
will likely end on july 1st street
fighter 2 was the game which made
one-on-one fighters the biggest genre in
the world this was really where it all
began in arcades so if you want to see
what all people like me called gaming in
the 1990s download capcom's arcade
stadium and pick up street fighter 2 for
free if you're quick enough
[Music]
another free game no let's not call it a
game another free experience is saints
row boss factory the new and improved
saints row is coming for gta's crown
next month in august and to wet our
appetite it's possible to create your
character now a highly detailed custom
creator can be used to waste countless
hours perfecting the right eyebrows or
to make complete abominations hench
firemen weird vampires i'm sure
someone's even made agent 47 by now and
in fact whilst i was researching this
the website here tracks a number of the
celebrity players people have made this
week look at this it's the rock i'll be
back soon to tell you all about the new
saints row because it's been a while
since gta had any competition but for
now boss factory is out right now so
someone please make shrek
and a huge free game is scheduled to
drop in july 2022 multiverses a platform
fighter good enough to rival smash bros
the open beta essentially the soft
release of the game is confirmed for
this month yet no fixed date is here
while i'm writing this last month the
closed beta took place and really
impressed a lot of people the premise is
to beat the living daylights out of each
other to a point where your opponent
cannot get back on the platform the plan
is to have this game around for years to
continuously update the roster with new
characters from warner brothers owned
franchises which means one day
effectively neo from the matrix could be
able to go up against whacking phoenix's
joker on day one 16 characters are
confirmed with vastly different move
sets and abilities dc heroes looney
tunes scooby-doo's greatests are here
and even arya from game of thrones no
form of media is off the table here
films tv shows video games cartoons they
can all be in this game there is great
depth to master yet it has this pick up
and play feel too so when the beta drops
i urge you to try it games like this can
have a scarily high skill ceiling and
being late to the party can make it even
harder multiversus could be the biggest
game of the year and it's totally free
to play
[Music]
back to full price games and f1 i don't
usually cover sports games because each
season their differences are so
negligible it's not worth our time but
this year it's like a new game f1 thanks
to the many rule changes in the real
world sport the digital world sport is
now forced to copy them and that gives
us f-122 there are new sessions like the
sprint race optimizing pit stops and
formation laps is now critical and here
you can even change your wallpaper in
your office
very f1 i guess and for those who want
to raise up the ranks like charles
leclerc and george russell there is also
f2 formula 2 to get your hands on if any
of that floats your boat look out for
f-122 on july 1st on pc xbox and of
course playstation
and one for the oldies now remember
clinoa it's been 25 years since the
platformer released and now we have
clinoa fantasy reverie series a
compilation of clonoa door to phantom
mill and clonoa 2 lunati's veil which
itself was a remake of the 2001 game
very meta i probably butchered so many
words there too this likely has a very
specific very niche audience and if
you're in it then know that clinoa now
runs at 60 frames a second and at 4k
with newly added difficulty adjustments
because old games were legit too hard
two-player co-op mode is confirmed too
look out for it on july 7th on
playstation xbox pc and switch oh and
finally a quick note that madison the
horror game we spoke of last month was
pushed back into july you can now be
scared poopless on july 8th instead so
what you're playing this month stray is
my jam this time around and i may give
arcade geddon a chance too but what
about you i'm adam you're awesome i'll
see you next time
[Music]
hey